on se situe pour l'instant sur la
hauteur de la butte et les citronniers
se situe en contrebas comme ça d'accord
le dernier vol remonte à cette affaire
au saint-esprit la plantation fait
trente hectares essentiellement de la
banane est des citronniers
elle emploie une vingtaine d'ouvriers
mais voilà lorsque les ouvriers s'en
vont une autre sorte de visiteurs
apparaît des voleurs et ils se servent
bien qu'on tourne je pense
une tonne de citron par récolte parce
que c'est pas une plante à ce vraiment
si tu comptes ce dernier qui sont
implantés le long des traces
ce n'est pas un champ de 6 3% en parler
mais l'union colleter de tonnes je perds
la moitié quoi miguel brito on a déjà
pris sur le fait et il a porté plainte
les gendarmes sont ici aujourd'hui pour
lui donner un coup de main
l'accumulation de ces vols sur de
petites propriétés met en danger les
équilibres financiers des agriculteurs
donc nous avons mis en place un
dispositif coordonné avec des motards
tout terrain des gendarmes donc officier
de police judiciaire qui suivent en
voiture et qui sont en capacité
d'interpeller les personnes qui se
trouvent de manière irrégulière dans les
exploitations agricoles et motards
partent sillonner les traces pour les
repérer les autres suivant 4 4 le
résultat ne tarde pas c'est bon ouais
c'est mais reçues on arrivera vous
rejoint par le bas
on reproche main
les reçoit pompiers l'homme repérer
prend la fuite il est rattrapé il n'a
pas de citron mais des bananes et une
moto sans plaquer son permis il faudra
vérifier s'il fait partie des visiteurs
réguliers de la plantation
pas le temps de souffler un autre appel
[Musique]
là aussi l'individu prend la fuite mais
il n'est pas rattrapé mais c'est une
surprise d'une autre sorte qui attend
les gendarmes un squat sur le terrain
d'à côté et derrière ces branchages du
crack et une arme de poing
parti sur une opération de contrôle les
gendarmes semblent avoir débusqué une
planque de trafic de drogue